my you should still work yes
Oh
you
to see how much penetration one for this
- my in range
oh if my steps are small then it all
take water shoots yours happens
I mean have to be out right then you
catch me in range
you
my body is going to turn so the record
is going to shield with this paint if it
doesn't go here we could move the angle
of deflection point from one side of my
outer rim to the other side of my outer
room this does not do it so with my hip
rotation
then when I come around I don't swing
the show with my right hand ding crowd
with my left that is a cosmetic yoga
language
the left hand reaches up and holds the
weapon the sweat got the difference
you
inside every attack there is a good
space if you have to fill the hit space
penetrating to the inferior border of
the mid space is what established this
connection so I go on it's right here
it's not over here I don't know he's
gonna do that I just came in trying to
do our hand forward I'm gonna keep that
in space oh don't let don't give up the
centerline prematurity and always come
back to it will he come off of it to the
great your angle deflection you
understand that but by maintaining as
long as possible that's where you
establish connection
the forum is going to change in a row so
you are coming in and you are entering
to skewer him it's going to be much
easier if you take that inertia it move
it over here if you're going here and
you're going back
you think that's human mentality so I
don't need to go back I go right and he
thinks that work look what was left out
I'm not protecting the centerline and
pretty much anything works but the
completion of my move is not only the
catalyst for his move like that's the
starting point but it provides the
reason for his mood so I gotta do
something in a way then pretty much the
only thing he can do is what the form is
prescribed hey so I don't reverse
engineering
I shouldn't have to go backwards because
he shouldn't be able to come forward got
it and then you reverse engineer all the
way like if I did the first move right I
wouldn't be able to go backwards and if
I did the first move right that requires
me to go forward he wouldn't be able to
come forward either so I go skewer fool
I'm protecting that centerline okay if
he skis on the other side of your body
right
his kids what's that i ug so I'm making
him go round you understand centralized
occupies so here
oh this worked perfectly and we starting
to and we're starting to rotate the
form we're not just trading sticks this
is not the fun there's a battle logic
rich body body back in don't drop the
shoulder you're taking your sin and grab
the outside your face to support
remember where he was you know in sand
or lie by this state here that is very
close very close so my body has to move
out of the way I'm moving tightened out
of the way this generates the power so
I'm back here boom
that's the power for the next shot boom
Joe up as it target it's gotta be
perpendicular to the meal okay it's not
here it's not a wrist which has the
power hand the left hand and the spine
try that
you